guess what movie is being rebooted
predator The Karate Kid yeah it's
actually really good
Hanna how do you get to see that we had
the guys that created the wrap-up show
and so they set this one unless you
would think of me once in a while and
send me that yeah what good does it do
of you see I don't know like Gary daddy
doesn't share with me why am I not
included if the Creator wants us to see
it do you send a note to us hey tomorrow
on the wrap-up show her that guys have
created Cobra Kai if you want here's a
link to look at it yeah and then what
and you watch it and thought it was good
and then what did you think I'm done
think of me and Steve's not thinking to
me and [ __ ] Jon hein isn't thinking
to me you guys hate me or something
hit him with the hind hit it with the
hind I know I'm not gonna give that
stuff
hi Gary its John I just saw the glow
Brooke I really liked it what do you
think
I think boss will love it but I bet not
send it to him cancel the wrap-up show
forever I mean really [ __ ] these guys
never think of me hmm
this t-bones a no just sent the new
Cobra Kai to the serious janitor who
cleans the bathrooms this guy's never
think of me they know I love like action
films big Karate Kid fans wouldn't we
want to pay attention to the reboot
you're here to serve your boss not John
hime why would you think of John Hyde
Steve said to John and I who is Steve
serving boss boss whenever in doubt ball
and it's John and me well listen we're
gonna start correcting my grammar around
here we're in big trouble be a WF be a
WF spells ball when I'm watching a
really good movie ball when I'm doing
something fun boss boss boss
BAW Boff Boff is my man when I see
something good when I hear something
good anything good I think ball have you
rejected you you want him to bring it up
right yeah and what's that sign you have
on your computer slow down slow down
take that down and put up ball B aw F
[ __ ] ball what good is being ball
around here you know what it is I'm too
nice